hey
we are live gentlemen
good morning good evening wherever the
hell you are in the world and welcome to
soundtrack your Sci-Fi TV and Movie
Channel and I am on my phone because
I've got children here that refuse to
get off the internet
and um it works better on my phone for
some reason
how are we all good doing well
I'm good I just got up
excellent still in bed oh five in the
evening stormy oh yeah yeah dude come on
man what are you doing
um
all right we're on today because we
started a let's call it a friendly
conversation
um uh Hey Shirley how are you hey
popcorn power hey Laura hey Jordan eater
Uh Kevin welcome everybody
um so um we had a conversation it was
very friendly at no point did I want to
kill um anybody during that conversation
um
so we were having a lovely conversation
um Eric from The Babylon five Alliance
how are you sir
um so
it was based on a story that Harris
you'd you'd put on
um I can't remember the guy's name now
but it was a writer director wasn't it
uh yeah it correlated with Mission
Impossible 7 having a bunch of AI in it
and then Stephen Soderbergh the
director's producer writer that guy he's
done a bunch we all love him uh he was
talking about how AI is much more of a
tool than it is an actual scary thing to
be replacing us people in the film
industry so we had a beautiful debate
about it and me being a complete
grown-up I I might have gone no you're a
tool
um but uh but yeah because I'm a
grown-up we had a what you could call a
mass debate
at no point did anybody threaten anybody
else so it was fine
um but we thought we'd continue thinking
because I I challenged you
to a jewel
um but I challenge you to come back with
this can you actually name a movie TV
show or whatever that could not be
produced by an AI something that is
actually original
the homework was can you think of any
ideas
um that were just totally original not
that couldn't be recreated by an AI
because everything's gonna be recreate
the AI because it's literally feeding
off our information no no you're right
my argument was that actually humans
haven't created anything that's
completely original for decades so and
my group was we shouldn't open the door
on AI because if if we do
um evil Executives have big long stashes
have gone all the time and we'll
actually use it and save money and load
of writers lose their jobs basically
that was my argument well I didn't know
I'm growing up this mustache yeah
exactly but your argument if it correct
me if I'm wrong was basically that no to
be creative and to do something original
you've got to be a human being
no no not necessarily to be original but
to be creative and I think originality
comes from creativity
I think it's too I think it's I think it
is entirely possible that church EPT
could come up with something no one else
has come up with but I don't think it
will have the creative spark that only
comes from humans yeah that's my entire
argument popcorn power just had a really
good uh comment he said Scott Adams
argument against AI writers is that an
AI cannot surprise you as it only
rehashes what has been done before
all right well a little bit of a a
little bit of an update I've got about
the right to strike so um I spoke to one
of my um Palestinians you know I said
about two weeks ago they got very
excited at the talent agency that the
guy I speak to works out and he said
they would they thought it's it was it
was about to be done apparently there
was a bit of a breakthrough that the
um
uh students and everything agreed
they basically matched the Director's
Guild deal to say that no AI can be
hired as a writer so that has been
agreed and AI cannot be hired as a
person is actually the way they've
worded it but that basically works out
that it can't be hired to write a script
so you cannot get a programmer to do you
a script
and then that script to be used you
would need it to be a writer all right
yeah um but they so they thought that
was it then they broke through that but
now the writers gave up without we will
want more money and that's the start of
the argument again so
um
well that's that's an interesting thing
hopefully hopefully we're gonna get
something this week because obviously
the Actors Guild only had an extension
but only till the 12th which give me
from wrong is Wednesday
uh yep so if if sagafter is going to go
on strike it'll be from Thursday
um
the only Stargate but the news I've
really got this week is is basically the
same as what we've said that they would
look they are still have open plans that
they will announce Stargate at
um San Diego Comic Con
unless the actors go on strike at which
case the chances are they won't
all right
um but anyway but we've always said that
is that's always that's been the same
for about three months so we'll see see
what happens with that
so
projects movies that are completely
original
from the last
two decades so you're saying
yeah most of these that I ever from the
last two decades
go on the house gives throw a swan out
you want to just throw your one out
there just uh just to get it I want your
favorite and then let's see um oh I
might be saying the wrong director but
I'm pretty positive it's it's Richard
link later he might come up here a
couple times but Richard uh link
lighters Boyhood and you see Boyhood the
movie that took uh 12 years to film
because it filmed an entire kid's
journey into manhood so it filmed his
entire Boyhood he'd pick up maybe once
one month maybe two months out of the
year and he'd film give him part of a
script he'd film get the whole cast uh
Patricia Arquette's in it
um a couple other people in her Ethan
Hawks in it I believe
great one uh
but yeah an AI is not going to think
I've not seen it but it's it's fiction
yeah they took 12 years to film it
probably just do a documentary
yeah division
he had a Creative Vision that an AI
couldn't have
so
I would say the original the idea is
original yes
and I I could rehash it and do it again
but I don't see an AI coming up with
okay let's film this over 10 12 years
because they are mathematical and they
want it to be efficient and they wanted
to be quick you're more likely to get a
90-minute script every time then
yeah let's make it two and a half hours
and and really
explore a concept or idea
I could definitely rehash that and redo
it but I think that yeah that's the
whole argument isn't it um it took a
human to have that idea
to be then fed into
chat GPT
and then it might split it out in the
future again but it would never have
done it on its own
yes yeah
but with the original idea it could then
do the script
so again you could cut out the right
essentially
I don't even do an outline
well I think there's a there's a couple
of examples that of things that AI just
could never come up with you know that
the the story is so disjointed but it
would take a human to sort it out and do
it properly one good example that's Pulp
Fiction
can you imagine if an AI tried to just I
mean it's already disjointed but it took
human craftsmanship to make it
understandable to humans you know you
know all the AI work we've seen it's all
very linear you know I was playing
around with a chat gbt this week you
know uh write me a short story for
whatever you know and it's all every
single time it's linear
you know so going back you know to
Boyhood I mean maybe because that's kind
of a linear story but Pulp Fiction
I just can't see that happening you know
or or something like uh Memento y'all
remember Memento that's another one that
was yeah I would say that was very I
mean redone a million times but if when
it first came out it was a very original
yeah plot
um and it was disjointed but again
now it's been done once you feed that
into an AI or if you ask an AI to do a
Quentin Tarantino style script it could
do it
it can try like
I did I did throw out the the Quentin
Tarantino write me shorts Quentin
Tarantino story
and it will still linear
I mean it was
so [__] up but it was fiction is
linears down there but Inglorious
Bastards and Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood are similar where they're not
like they are a little more linear and
they might be able to come up with
something like that but that alternate
history thing I think it struggles with
because it has to
have a certain set of history or or
whatever to be plugged in for it to
follow I don't know if it does a really
good job at uh switching that up at
times
but it and we would be talking about
more advanced algorithms and more
advanced program than what we're using
you know over of this then then what's
available to you know Executives that
are going to have a more expensive
version
with more import more algorithm or data
points successful output very linearly
though yeah and and not you're not gonna
software all it is a software taking in
an input it's essentially the same as
that
um
the input from your mouse you're moving
up and down that's a binary input are
you going up you're going down you go
left you're going right and everything
in between
AI is very
very much the same
at its core it's just lots of little
inputs which then determine an outcome
but it's not I don't think it's ever
going to be any different because it's
software it's programs which run line by
line code by code it can't go outside of
its programming so if you had a function
so in program you have functions and
these functions determine like what's
going to happen next in the code if you
had in the function
if this then that okay
that program is never going to go
then this if that that's never going to
go in reverse it can't because it always
has to go if this then that it can't
change the way it thinks it can't
reprogram itself
that's one of the points of ai ai does
currently I promise misconception it
doesn't reprogram itself the program
does not reprogram itself it just has
more inputs that it can learn from it's
not on the Matt's point is uh AI you
know if it's coming up with random ideas
it still has to be the random seed has
to be developed
you know and a random seed is always
something that is appointed to something
yeah it can come up with a it can
randomize the random seed but the
randomizer is still itself seated from
something that is uh non-random
could be the time of day or the random
seed could be you know whatever your
passcode is for your ATM I mean anything
can be random or it could be an image it
could be an image this is a random seed
but it has to be seated
yeah I'm programming Randomness is
incredibly hard yeah like
everything that you if you type if you
go on to Google now and you have a a
random number generator it's not
actually going to be random it's going
to be a pro it's going to be a
programmed generator yes it's going to
appear random but it's never going to be
truly random because it's programmed
because it's following a set of
instructions and it may be a really
complex algorithm so the best example I
can think of this is the Minecraft
worlds they have seats those seats are
64-bit um integers which determine how
that world is going to procedurally
generate now that is a
a random seed really isn't it's just a
hash function which is just pulling out
um specific oh no
arbitrary values and then putting them
together
but it's not really random because it's
pulling them from somewhere it knows
where to look it's not just going do you
think humans can Generate random
yeah we can't
you might understand the computer side
of things but I understand the
psychology things are better humans
don't Generate random
I would say we can Generate random but
we are similar to computers in that way
where we can be if like I went to the
Magic Castle like a month ago and one of
their big things was like we're gonna
make you say we're gonna make this
person say a sentence that we all know
that they're going to say by the end of
like the thing and you can really you
can program someone's brain to do that
but once again you have to prompt it we
don't need to be prompted to come up
with those numbers so I think we can
come up with random numbers but if we
have any kind of numbers in front of us
we're going to be more likely to put
that in front of us yeah but we don't
know if you ask somebody to come up with
a set of random numbers statistically
speaking more often people pick three
and seven
um yeah there are certain things that
there's because and then today our brain
works it's far more complicated than
um the current AI because it's not
really AI we keep calling it AI good
it's not really yeah but um
but we our brains work by categorization
and by um
basically past experience so we have a
system the same as that and we don't
Generate random
we don't we don't generate Randomness
either
um so I mean how is that different again
how is the the computer system different
it's just maybe a little bit simpler but
every year it gets twice as complicated
so
well me me and a neurologist friend of
mine we were discussing this issue kind
of about
um
identifying people you know not not like
in a um biometric point of view but
but
um showing how everybody is the original
experiment the original idea was showing
everybody's on a spectrum so you would
take you'd ask the person questions like
what's your favorite food
what's your favorite color what's your
favorite genre of music you know uh
philosophy of a sparrow sorry right so
you know you start building up all of
these things that people like and then
you also dislike and after you get to
that like 10 or 20 Questions down you're
in such a rarefied pie of humanity that
it is very distinctive like nobody likes
you know there's very few people that
you know is x amount of inches high or
likes peas or you know also likes rap
but a little bit of Funkadelic and it
just once you you know find determine up
someone's personal likes or and dislikes
it becomes very individualized and it is
almost almost
like every person is their own random
seed but that doesn't change unless you
know but it can over time but it's not
it's not something that you know your
your like of peas or dislike of peas
doesn't change every 30 nanoseconds
they reckon psychologically you have
roughly a seven year cycle where
um basic character
um oh I forget the proper word for it
but we our characters are built up with
these basic character and foundations
that that that roughly can change every
seven years or so yeah
um and um obviously it's a bit more
complicated but they just mentioned that
the Blaze and saddles in the comments
that Nai couldn't come up with the end
of Blazer Saddles but the end of Blazer
Saddles was written because they ran out
of money
so they ran out of money in the studio
basically said you've got to be off the
lot in two days and they're like oh crap
so Mel Brooks being the genius that he
is when
we'll just do this random end and it'll
be funny and we'll do that but it was
never supposed to be the end of the
movie
it was forced on them
but could a computer come up with that
in that same amount of time or would it
need a certain amount of guidelines
could it have that creative original an
idea and that like amount of time
I see I think a computer would have
probably come up with
an ending that fits the story and it
probably wouldn't have worked as well as
um
yeah I would argue though 100 that I
think the one area that AI 100 struggles
now would struggle now and may never
quite get
is comedy
because I don't think it would comedy
quite Works to a set of rules
um a lot of comedians will say look
there's comic timing and those things
and you can learn certain aspects of
Comedy but when you see a comedian and
he's about to go on tour he doesn't
write his tour to a set of sort of
normal rules that he's learned over the
years what he'll do is he'll write a
tour and then he goes on a pre-tour
where he does lots of little gigs and
I've because I've seen this a couple of
times because we've got um a studio a
studio
a theater by us there's quite a little
theater and there's always like Lee
Evans has done it and I saw a Michael
McIntyre there we saw Jason man for not
long ago and they on these pre-tours
and all the way through he's like
scribbing things out that didn't work
and this joke but they make a joke out
of the fact that they're like writing
it there and then and certain things
don't work and I mean Jason manford's
been in the business 20 years and he
still cracks a joke and it just doesn't
work so he just scratches It Off
I'm not sure there are a set of rules
and I think AI would struggle and I'm
not sure it would ever it might be able
to do like a rom-com it might be able to
do things like that and generic comedy
but I don't think it would ever
replace a human being on being's
Instinct for comedy I would think the
same thing for a horror movie or like a
scary movie I think I could do like the
pop-up like easy scares but I don't
think I could do like a psychological or
I don't think it could bring Silence of
the Lambs about any day of the week I
don't think it could bring the original
Exorcist or something like that around
even The Conjuring or Insidious I think
it'd be much more of uh if it was going
to go that route it'd be like the woman
in black where it's it's still spooky
but it's it's very much surface level
spooky and it's like here's a about
horror here's a pop out scare here's the
I think it would be much more
mathematical in that sense where it
doesn't feel or organic at all where
it's because it's trying to write what
is a ghost to a a computer what is a
demon to a computer you know I don't
know if they truly understand the
concepts between what we give what is
anything to a computer though it needs
to be have it explained to it doesn't it
what is anything to a computer nothing
it's nothing it's a set of data points
which has to heard the ability to create
creatively that's how our brains work
though as well our brains work by we
have sets of we categorize things but we
we even although we're trying we we try
to categorize it which is part of our
creativity so much we're a computer if
they can't categorize it they'll toss it
out in a recycle bin we start thinking
about oh okay so if if this isn't a
ghost right here could that be someone
like playing a trick on somebody over
here is it some weird machine or is it
an extraterrestrial what our brain goes
to four five six seven different avenues
like a computer would but I don't think
an AI is it has to be pre-programmed to
even try to figure something out like
that out you know it's not going to do
that nothing computers have had problems
oh the kids have taken back over
Oh I thought
over it's my mind you're losing me we
have no idea what you just said
oh because I can I I didn't see any
difference on my side so I guess
um so one of the problems that our
computers have with identifying things
so it's basically if you say right
here's a is a box and it's got windows
and four wheels and an engine and you
say right that is a car
and but then Elario go by and it'll go
car no no no that's a lorry because
that's bigger and it's different and it
pulls things so it's a lorry okay and
then you'll see somebody like a bicycle
with one of those pulley things behind
and go oh it's a lorry no no no it's a
bicycle and that that's the problem with
it you have to have so many data points
and we
our brains cut corners on that and we
sort of like go at a car I know that's a
car and then a child will learn to
categorize that and this those
categorizations is why we make some
psychological mistakes
where will you see something at a
distance and you think it's something
and then you realize guess question
releases something completely different
or
um there's lots we actually learn a lot
from our psychology of learning when the
brain makes a mistake why it makes a
mistake and it cuts Corners a lot
teaching computers to do that has been
the trick but they were getting quite
good at it so first question I got for
you
if we say AI is this good now
and it has its limitations obviously
what do you think it will be capable of
doing in 10 years
I don't even think that's a real
question because how are we supposed to
answer that I just didn't have to let it
happen
because you can see what what what's AI
doing in the last 10 years where do you
think it could we're and we're talking
about writing scripts and and basically
faking human creativity it couldn't do
it at all 10 years ago where are we are
now where could it be in another 10. so
about a million so about a million years
ago when I was in college
um right everything was black and white
it literally was black and white right
even the green screen monitors were in
black and white it was so long so
um
I wanted somebody to play D D with all
the time so I came up with this thing it
was a gen it was a dungeon generator you
know and uh the the little nugget that
kept everything straight was the
Curiosity kit you know it was it really
wasn't random scenarios I mean it was
partially random I should say but it
came up with these scenarios for me to
go through and it was like on an Apple
too it was really simple but I called it
the Curiosity generator and right now in
somebody from the chat will probably
know what this is but there's a branch
of AI
that is like that and going on to
Harris's Point earlier he was talking
about you know the computers would just
throw things out into the trash and but
we'll we may be working through a
promises oh this is kind of cool you
know we'll write it on the post in it or
we may go down this whole path and
whatever this new branch of AI is it's
that's similar to uh the Curiosity
generator
you know I think that is the branch of
where
Network creativity will go to and I
think it it it's you know it's all again
a matter of bandwidth I believe you know
especially when Quantum Computing got it
is insanely expensive but if you look at
what Quantum Computing could be in 10
years and then overlap that with the
application of AI
Terra deck AI
uh that would um
I mean I I think
I think we may get close to uh having AI
as a creator of media a very good
creator of media that can kind of come
up with stuff on its own now there may
be uh AI meeting media creators that are
specialized in westerns or sci-fi or
vampire novels whatever
but um
as I said it is just a matter of time
money and technology for this to solve
itself
right
kind of greedy
not really I can't I kind of I I think
at some point
I I kind of agree
they probably will get to the point at
some point where it will be what you
would call an intelligence that it would
be able to do
like some remarkable things but at the
moment
and even in the next 10 years 20 years I
don't think it's going to be a risk
because
AI Now isn't clever AI now is is a large
language model essentially and all it is
is like four billion data points or
eight billion data points or 10 billion
data points or whatever
right
if it was
given the task now
to write software
it would do it really well because
software is
programmatic it's logic based it's the
set of rules that you cannot like get
around
if it was to write
sorry this my headset just finished
charging and it wouldn't stop beeping at
me if
um if it was asked to write literature
or something like that I think it would
struggle massively
if it was to write something original
because it's very different than writing
programs with a set a set of rules which
are programmatic and which essentially
we've had these rules for programming
since the Inception of computers it's
literally
moving moving bytes of data around
on
on the the idea of it creating
literature or creating scripts or
creating anything
that humor would normally do
it would struggle because the way
authors write and the way script right
is right language they use is very
nuanced in a lot of ways it's very
the the the reason they choose
particular words
doesn't necessarily follow the rules
that we were all taught in school
for writing English sometimes they
choose to to to to say something
completely different but we as a reader
can understand what it means and we can
draw and read between the lines and
things like that but I don't think an AI
would ever
be able to do that unless obviously
unless it was an actual intelligence and
not just a program going off of the past
it's a different story
relay oh yeah if it was real artificial
intelligence if it was Skynet for
example
like that is actual intelligence but the
the AI we're talking about isn't
intelligence it's just a really really
good algorithm really good algorithm
well I looked up the uh the Curiosity
generator but the modern term for it is
and it is called generative AI genetic
API creating synthetic media
so that's the the branch of AI that does
um
uh image creation and to an extent music
I think
mid-journey Dolly all that kind of stuff
yeah yeah
I think the most interesting question
I've ever heard about AI
is
um
you know the first step is you know the
Turing test how you know having a AI
that is indistinguishable having a
conversation with you that's
indistinguishable from a human
you know but the the thing that really
terrifies me in terms of AI is when do
we have the first AI that purposely
fails the Turing test
right
because I mean for me that would be a
signifier intelligence
more than anything else potentially is
when you
have the ability to lie almost yeah
because that's self-aware and protection
isn't it trying to protect itself so
yeah that that applies that the air has
fear and is is fearful for being shut
down or has an agenda has plans Beyond
its programming kind of thing and that's
when you start playing Tic-Tac-Toe with
it immediately
well okay
Battleship and you what
come on Harris what are you saying no uh
just just with with AI all this thought
process in general I'm I'm kind of with
with both with Nat and stormy on here I
think um uh with Stormy in about 30
years instead of 10 years though because
even just the amount of quantum
Computing we have right now is nothing
we've got like
maybe 10 20 30 quantum computers on on
this planet just because I thought we
only had two so yeah I I was highballing
it because just because I don't know the
actual number like I'm just
guesstimating but and that's it whether
it's a real quantum computer or not yeah
because Google's is listening oh is it
quantum love they have to put at a
certain level underwater to even have it
operable because of how hot it goes I
don't think that's going to be
commonplace in 10 years and and that's
going to be a necessity for robots to be
at the place where we consider them true
AIS in 10 years or or 20 30 40 50 60 80
years whatever it happens I think the
box has been open Pandora's Box is open
so we will get there but I don't think
that that I think we're as people we're
fear-mongering ourselves a little bit by
saying like 10 years from now yes the
job everything everything we know of as
of right now will be looking very
different but it won't be different in a
way that doesn't feel like Humanity you
know I don't think we're getting to the
Terminator robots I don't think we're
getting to see 3PO I don't think we're
getting the iRobot and Isaac asimov's
Sunny either anytime soon Sunny will be
our true AI but think about the rest of
the robots in there
those are those are what we would
consider AI right now to to the degree
that we consider AI now I I think we
have many many years of playing around
with this before any true AI comes about
and if it does come about it probably
would be in that like Central kind of
thing uh I don't remember what the the
character is in asimov's book or iRobot
the movie but the uh the central uh
thing that they have to take out at the
end that Sonny's the only robot that's
not part of it kind of the Mainframe uh
I I think hopefully if once we actually
do get to all this of course I'm I'm the
on the Star Wars route put it all in
C3PO and different things like that put
it in an individual thing so each
individual robot has the choices to make
instead of some big brain controlling
tens of thousands of robots or a
thousand robots or a hundred robots here
or there the boys if we can yeah
okay so with that that's we talk about
like originality there then we we think
that
um to actually do something truly
original an AI needs to be far more
advanced than it is now we think you can
get there but it actually needs to be
really loud to feel intelligence fine
well I'm not really worried about that
though because I think there'll always
need be need the writers and when we do
something really considerate obviously
think about sci-fi
you get the really high concept science
fiction movies TV series I think that
requires an element that AI can't do
because you need something that original
spark that original whatever
ninety percent of TV in movies though I
would say maybe isn't that original
and that is quite
generic and formulaic right that's the
sort of thing I think the AI could
pretty much do now
but let's say five look it didn't it
basically wasn't a thing five years ago
where we are now I think it'll be better
in another five years and I think maybe
that's when we're at the risk
the only reason why I'm bringing up this
argument now is I think we need the
rules now
for writers so they don't start losing
their jobs in 10 years with this this is
this is why it's been a certain way
so can AI in say five years do
75 of the work writers do now
I I I uh this was part of a point
earlier as well
um uh we kind of trailed off into like
the or not trailed off but we went into
the conceptual aspects of AI versus I
guess uh uh another thing you started
out that last question with was
um
a good Lord brain fart hello uh but but
uh give me a second I'll be back so
while he's Gathering his boss let me
just add them together
why is gathering slots uh IBM announced
last year that they have over 20 quantum
computers 20.
oh oh damn that's that's more than I
expected so I I was in the right range
okay but I did remember so chat GPT just
because that's that's the thing that
we're thinking about probably that's
writing scripts right now I you were
saying the studios may have just such a
they can afford a much different version
that's that's much better than what we
have as a public
Etc I don't think that's true at all
because what what they were maybe paying
extra for six months ago is what chat
gbt4 is now and you can pay 10 to 20 a
month for it uh I don't I don't think
we're that far behind and as long as
that's the case and I don't think many
studios I don't think any of the big
studios I don't think Warner Brothers or
Disney would go spend a hundred thousand
dollars on an AI right now they don't
have the type of money to do that if
they need to spend that type of money
they're putting into a project somewhere
if they wouldn't have the capacity to
know how to even do it anyway but the
actual time it takes to train an AI is
insane like people think you can just
put in some data and it will just go
through a thousand iterations you'd have
to hire a whole new Department it takes
months if not years to train
anywhere closer than like a million no
do you generally think they wouldn't
spend
10 million dollars on a project to
create an AI Department if it means they
could sack 75 of the writers
but if you have to keep those 75 riders
for the next eight years while you're
programming it yes because they're
spending way too much money on that they
would do that though I mean because
these are companies
I think we're always looking for the
next big thing of course they would
spend that sort of money it's nothing I
don't think so because there is chat
gpt4 and opportunities like that where
you can pay a little more to have that
same type of thing on a more personal
level and I think they pay for the
personal stuff over paying one giant
blanket price I think they'd be like
these these are good Riders let's give
each of them access well 20 bucks a
month that's nothing give them give them
that yeah you kind of makeup I actually
think one of these things will be
something like
something that's open sourced in a way
or that lots of people use because then
can't the program isn't that then adding
more data points for free sort of thing
and the more input you have the better
the software it eventually gets so you
would have some of that but then Disney
would pay
the provider of that to have a version
of that that it then uses for these
scripts and things but then that's the
point that when you're if you're making
like an action movie you've got like
three scenes you know you've got your
three parts of the action movie The here
you've got a hero you've got a villain
you've got an anti-hero it's not
complicated 90 of action movies are not
complicated
all you have to do is show I know this
isn't quite how it works but my stupid
brain you all you have to do is show an
AI a bunch of 80s action movies and then
go create me a movie like that please
that's it and then it but it might not
be able to do that you know that really
creative
die hard when it first came out action
movie but it can create all the other
tribes I mean could genuinely think it
wouldn't write The Expendables no well
maybe okay The Expendables yes The
Expendables yes and my brain went to
Jackie Chan like you could plug in 100
Jackie Chan movies and then say hey
write me a fight sequence like at Jackie
Chan and they're never gonna write you a
fight sequence like Jackie Chan
because because it's Reliant upon the
actors on the day he literally changes
things that like on day in camera inset
hey I cannot do that they happen to have
to find things that massively
choreographed and
I tell you that there are there are sets
of rules
for when you yeah I mean I've done a bit
of training and things like that and
there's significant sets of rules for
when you train for that and yeah and I
would say of course you could teach an
AI to do that again it may be struggling
doing something then different
but there's so many movies out there
with so many fights I mean
um in Karate For example there's only
about 70 Moves something like that
and then there's then there's just
variations of a theme which an AI can do
you guys are basically argue that's what
AI does it takes a set of rules and it
can do variations of a theme
well I'd like to bring up um
a couple points I think it is there's a
book that if you work for Pixar
uh I think there's a book that you have
to read before during your orientation
and I think it's called story
um
that you know it's like the Bible of
Storytelling you know there's another
quote unquote Bible of Storytelling you
know it was
um
Poetics by
um narcart not Archimedes
um
let me just uh kill that out so it was
oh what let's see who wrote Poetics
thank you
there is a set of rules that I mean look
at Kevin feige
Aristotle wrote Poetics which was more
or less the art of how to tell a story
so there are these kind of rules or
whatever you know but I do think AI is
really far behind I put a a chat an open
AI uh Link in the chat is like I asked
the
um Chad gbt that to write me a short
story based on Tarantino Tarantino's
movies and the it is absolutely horrible
you know the the my favorite line in it
is quote Quentin Tarantino's signature
dialogue crackled through the air as the
characters navigated through a maze of
dark humor violence and unexpected
twists ah so there that's just you know
it's on the money
it's on the money or
money and then all you need to see is
say the c word and shoot somebody in the
face
um and that's the thing I think Quentin
Tarantino would put in a movie YouTubers
because he's quite self-deprecating he
pokes on his own work at times so maybe
but um that's just something back to
this point of like doing a generic
movie series whatever I mean if you tell
AI Maybe not today maybe in five years
but you turn one of these GPT nines say
do me a vampire series that'll appeal to
teenagers and you're telling me it won't
do it
no they need somebody to actually go get
it and make sure it makes sense 20 or 30
years it's not going to know what
appeals to teenagers it's gonna yeah to
teenagers 30 years
not being told what to do I'm saying you
tell it what to do an executive says I
want a vampire teen movie and it'll just
look at what is what's been done before
it won't understand it what appeals to
teenagers that's what I mean it's not
going to understand Buffy no no no you
show it Buffy and all it's going to see
you think Buffy would do well if it came
out today
no but you know what I mean you show it
past you you tell it that you just pump
it a bunch of scripts into it and say
this is the sort of thing I want
right
this is this is what I mean it doesn't
understand what you're showing it
it doesn't need to it just it just needs
to follow the effective rules if you if
you're asking it to create something
that's going to appeal to a certain
demographic of course it has to
understand it that's literally the point
of a writer it has to understand what's
what the target audience wants to see or
read about but isn't the understanding
of what that is just based on a set of
rules
no I think it's more nuanced than that
it's based on experience it's based on
emotion like it's like
it's not something you can program like
with a 50 year old executive or a 50
year old writer knows what teenagers
want
sometimes you might have he might have a
granddaughter or a kid or he might have
a goddaughter or a godson yeah I think
Executives a lot of the time think they
are telling you what you want I think a
lot oh I mean that's part of it for sure
but that doesn't mean a human's not more
applicable in figuring out what a human
likes and a robot is see I I don't even
know if we can ever have a computer of a
sufficient level to even understand what
any teenager wants
14 year old kids here and I genuinely
think they're aliens I think they've
been kidnapped
so I mean that's I just don't think I
just think that
it seems to me that it would be that
that's exactly what AI does pump out
generic
formulaic scripts it's doing it now
they're not great but it's doing it now
in five years it might do it a lot
better
no no that makes sense
um but you wouldn't need a writer to do
that then because the AI would do all
the hard work and then you basically
just need a secretary to go through and
make sure it makes sense yes and no yeah
no in the sense it's it's not going to
be able to do that yes in the sense
where you could train a specific AI to
do that in somebody's specific voice but
it will never bring anything original
still you you'd have to give it like
everything
we're not talking about original anymore
they would struggle today what I'm
saying is it it would still struggle
I I think it's still struggle see my my
problem with with this
um why I kind of just create all generic
stuff like we've been able to do that
for the last 10 years
like it's not a new thing to like if
they if they really wanted to do that
they would have done it
I don't say they've started to do it
I don't think I wouldn't say because
you're basically saying that they're
going to do it for nine percent of like
the crap that comes out of Hollywood I'm
saying they could not that they would
but they could but I don't think of
course they could they could have done
it 10 years ago they could have done it
yesterday could they could could have
done it anytime within the last like I
win no right because no because they
wouldn't because it's stupid because all
it's going to do because
if you just say to a computer right I
want it to have three acts and it's
going to have this character and this
character in this character write me a
right miscope of course it can probably
do that
it's not gonna be good though
it's not going to be worth putting money
into like because it's gonna
if
if they're pumping stuff out at a rate
um
like to get to get like script level
like outputs it's gonna cost a lot
right
it's not going to be cheap if they're
not going to be using the free version
of chat GPT that we're using they're
going to be they're going to be
investing money into it
to get a decent output but it's not
going to give a decent output if you
just give it generic like oh just look
at all the crap films we've had the last
50 years and make something out of that
it's just gonna make more crap and it's
not going to be worth the time because
it does it can't create it can't
it doesn't understand
it just looks it just looks at what it
thinks is positive and positive points
and like detract the points essentially
yeah so and you're basically saying that
it could create a piece of artwork but
there's always that
and I would argue here that we're
talking when something is actually good
and a lot of stuff on
our screens isn't necessarily good and
what I'm trying to say is I think
Executives could use AI
cut out the writers and create an awful
lot of stuff that's also not very good
very quickly and it would be cheaper and
they could pump out scripts much faster
and I think there is that possibility if
Executives and students were allowed to
do it and luckily it looks like they're
not going to be allowed to do it and
that's that's the point
if you did
it's only yeah it's only going to get
better though
it's not going to get worse it's just
gonna have more data points to go from
we still get better
it'll get better it learns more and it
learns and it has more data point the
more data what happens when it gets a
trillion data points or two trillion
data points
you know I don't think it helps us
creativity my rebuttal to the the that's
true why wouldn't they want absolutely
true you won't get yeah data points
don't data points almost negate
creativity because it's just it's trying
to throw data points in there instead of
being fun with and interesting with what
they already have you don't necessarily
need an extra two three four five six
trillion data points you you really only
need 30 or 40 and then if you are
creative enough you can make that 30 or
40 into a good story ai's never going to
do that it's it's like you know if
you're trying if you have a meeting the
more participants in a meeting the less
you get done yeah it doesn't necessarily
mean that meeting is going to be the
quality you have with the work product
well my rebuttal to uh why why wouldn't
they just do this because they can then
pump out loads of loads of this content
yeah of course they they absolutely
could
but the quality of the work that they
put out is going to suffer
which is just going to dig them a grave
because we've already seen it over the
last
how long has YouTube been up like 15
years
like the quality of stuff that comes out
from the big studios is now being
rivaled by smaller creators who now
being like powered by a chat GPD
essentially and all these AI tools can
create like amazing content
yeah big studios are probably going to
use it for the wrong wrong reason but
the small people who want to get a leg
up in the creative world and use it as a
tool
but we'll
we'll go to the top is that the future
then actually using something like this
to let you get Maybe
a lot of the grunt work done have
created quickly but then a writer still
needed to actually make it interesting
make it good make it so it's sort of
like how when we went from typewriters
to word processors to this is sort of
like that next iteration of the word
process starts doing a bit more of the
work for you yeah writers are inherently
just creative people
this is a tool for creativity they may
not be necessarily their pen and paper
or keyboard and mouse typing out scripts
in the future but they're still going to
be creating
using chat GPT as a tool as one of their
many Tools in their Arsenal that's
that's how I see it's going to be it's
going to the the Creator economy
is gonna like
lift itself massively
because of tools like this there's way
more tools coming up Jack gbt it's not
the be-all end all of of intelligence
it's not even like no especially when
you've got when you've got
um darlene2 Mid Journey like they're all
right at the moment but they're going to
get better because the more the more uh
images it gets fed
and let's see the thing I think where
it's really going to shine is where they
pull it into software
so
the AO will learn how you use the
software to make your experience
better so instead of having shortcuts
like you might have control K to like
skip the test slicer
slice a clip in the in After Effects or
whatever it is
like it will know when you're
potentially going to slice a clip and it
will just learn from you I think that's
that's how AI is going to help
creatives
but yeah I mean what do you think what
do you think about what I said about
like the writers thing though because I
think that's an interesting point
what was the point sorry okay okay I
glazed over it's that AI is not
necessarily going to like like
individuals can still
are necessary and like like the other
day kind of is that what you were saying
kind of like how we were talking about
how like
we could have a whole another generation
of George Lucas's now because of AI
versus instead of it death by committee
instead of that because that's what
writer's rooms tend to be I don't think
it will be because of AI I don't think
AI is going to do all the work all I'm
saying is AI is going to be a tool which
makes creativity easier yes and gives
people who are not necessarily
so so the example I gave was YouTube
back in the day when I started YouTube
in 2008 2009
like just using crappy cameras in my
bedroom right
now we have all this technology where we
can literally live stream
to
however many thousands of people we want
because of people who started out back
then
the creator of economy rose up I think
AI tools are going to help the Creator
economy rise up even more and it's just
going to be a tool it's not going to be
something that replaces creativity is
going to Aid creativity That's My
overall point it's the great equalizer
in a lot of ways I mean Hollywood's been
at the head of its game you know it it
Hollywood is
big man in charge on campus over here
all the time hey now Bollywood tollywood
uh those filmmakers in Nigeria those
those kids that are all a big group of
kids they have they have the exact same
tools and references that Hollywood has
now so it's kind of the great equalizer
in that sense where anybody anywhere can
make anything
and it doesn't need to be some fancy
high paid script writing room in
Hollywood where it's all these people
and and I'm probably pooping pooping a
little bit too much because I do want to
be in these big old high paid Hollywood
writers rooms once that one day but at
the same time I I'd much prefer a
populace of create creatives that are
able to
they might not get a big old movie made
but they can make a little YouTube
series and if AI is uh good at animating
for you down the road and you can give
it a certain style give it certain
whatever you can do that and even hire
an animator because it's a lot cheaper
because you already have all that
animation done to to work around the
edges to make it really tweak into the
things you want it to be and
everything's a lot cheaper in that sense
where you have lead work done for you
versus uh but before you get to the
creative aspects of it you know you you
can use it as a tool anywhere it's
everything everywhere all at once for
for us first little folk
yeah now I can say that I can say that
the points are nuts do you think that
then if if this deal is is right and
we've already got the deal with the
directors the AI can't be used as a
person
um and this is a as a general
way of sort of policing this in the
future regardless because we don't we
don't know how good GPT 10 will be
you can't sit there and tell me the
gpt10 won't be able to write
a hit movie
you can do it now
um but
it can't because Hollywood will agree
these certain rules is that enough well
uh you know you know I don't care how
crappy the the film would be that for
gbt 10 you know Netflix will buy at
least one season of it
that was very creative that won the best
picture Oscar that was then actually
sort of commercially popular
okay well that's one of my examples I
have written down right here Avatar
Jordan peels get out oh it you mean oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yep best picture he said not just an
Oscar right it's one of the first times
a horror movies I think it's the first
time a horror movie won best pictures in
Silence of the Lambs
and that was
2017. essentially popular was that very
I can look up where we've made money
because it it's it didn't cost much to
make
255.4 million dollars on a 4.5 million
dollar budget
okay I would argue that's that's a
decent hit and very good for the studio
but I mean Indiana Jones which is
considered a massive flop is going to
make that
well because it's
pretty expensive how many people
actually went out their way to watch it
is my point
that's that's a lot I mean it's a horror
movie as well it's Indiana Jones is one
of the greatest and it's a very original
thing from a first-time director who
people are very hesitant to go see
because it's a horror movie versus key
and peel that we're all used to which
people didn't just go rush to the
theaters because of that about two weeks
after is when they started going to the
theaters and that's that's a huge hit
and there's there's that's a very big
hit very very big hit okay that's a
commercial success because of our much
money it costs to make
I don't think that's maybe the same as
saying it was a Blockbuster oh no that's
that is a definite Blockbuster for the
horror friend for a horror anything
for the genre yeah
a thousand percent there's no doubt
about that one so that is the I was
quick would you agree then at least
normally the movie that wins best
picture
um not every year because I mean I think
um uh actually didn't um a couple of The
Lord of the Rings win best picture but
generally speaking the the creative
movie that critics love that wins best
picture at the Oscars generally isn't
commercially
hugely successful
did Titanic win best picture
we're about 15 Oscars but yeah
I think if um Lord of the Rings won any
Oscars I mean in terms of best picture
it would have been Return of the King or
maybe that was just uh Jackson's Oscar
but I think generally speaking if I hear
a movie wins best Oscar I'm thinking
well I'm not going to watch it then
because that's going to be boring
generally speaking
yeah they're they're they're they're
they're based I think you're right
because basically it's these surprise
movies that no one ever you know what
was one I think that was uh the Life of
Pi everybody just fell over head over
heels and I watched it I was rooting for
the tiger yeah I was really hoping the
tiger would just go eat on that [__]
but it just didn't happen I'm sorry to
smack the characters into the ocean and
they drown and that'd be the end of the
film because it was awful it was
confused it was very creative very
original in AI would have no chance and
it was [__]
yeah it was just boring
I sat next to the the lady that was the
mom and life of Pai one day uh me and
one of my friends from uh my hometown
came to visit LA and I was like okay
we'll go to Melrose and we'll go to like
some of the cool little like touristy
spots and hang out we went to this one
little lunch place
a little sandwich place on Melrose we
sat down
I I just hear the voice I'm sitting
right next to the uh uh uh I think her
name is like parmander nagra or
something like that was just sitting I
just kind of like froze and was like oh
[__] that sounds about right uh and then
right after we were sitting next to her
and her husband Kumail and Johnny comes
down next to my friend so I've I've had
lunch about three feet away from Kumon
and Johnny I don't think we spoke more
than like 20 words that entire time we
were just like just just eat your food
just don't make eye contact it was good
let me assistant and then is would it be
fair to say
and I don't know I can almost Matthew
getting annoyed immediately would AI be
good at making
stomach blockbusters
um movies that just Entertain You just
throw popcorn in your face and they'll
actually make craploads of money for the
studios no because it doesn't understand
what it's doing it wouldn't be creative
you need to understand of course it does
no it doesn't that's why these are all
of the set of rules for the exactly make
something creative you need to
understand the creative process you need
to understand what the audience you just
you just asked for instead of all of
Marvel phase one two three you just
asked for only marble phase four that's
what you just asked for and that was not
successful I don't think people are
going to go out and see that either they
we don't like that foreign world I would
argue that Marvel phase one and two were
way more formulaic it is when they're
trying to be more creative and try to do
something a bit different that we got
phase four
no we got phase three which was the most
successful like phase of any film thing
ever and then we got Play Store creative
and we've got [__] things full we
didn't didn't try to be more creative
they just put it out on the the lower
people Kevin [__] was like okay you
kind of know the formula you know the
formula you know the formula take these
start getting into the Multiverse of
Madness and they start trying to do
different types of movies
formula that was making it simpler and
handing it off to other people that
wasn't Kevin [__] doing that anymore
that was hey you know how to this works
you know how this works try it out
and that's why we don't like it all that
much if if even if even if that's the
thing if you're still going super
strictly formulaic you need a creative
head at that at that base somewhere you
either need the foundation to be
creative or you need the head to be
Foundation or the head to be creative
you know what I mean uh
uh it just doesn't work without an
actual creative uh I'm sorry a conduit
an AI a bunch of Iron Man comics and say
I want to do an Iron Man movie are you
telling me it could not have written the
first Iron Man movie
based on a certain lot of formulas to
say we want three things we want at one
point it's one point it looks like the
hero's got to be about to lose and then
he's got to be hero and you know you you
give it a bunch of rules to run by
because I tell you what the only real
example of this I've got is I've
listened to the Stargate scripts that
were written by AI for the companion
website and they basically threw in a
bunch of stagger episodes and told us to
create a Stargate episode and it created
a perfectly good Stargate episode and it
did it twice
okay well I'm I'm don't get mad at me
everybody but that's I I love Stargate
but the writing is not the strong suit
of Stargate the writing actually pointed
well it's it is because if you have a
better writer a better TV show it's not
going to come up with a Game of Thrones
episode it's not going to come up with a
house the Dragon episode Stargate as
much as I effing love it the acting is
what makes it that good the writing is
not that good the code the concepts are
there dragons oh my God the concepts are
there
I'm sorry I love you all but like all
the Stargate people everywhere but the
the writing is the definition of
formulaic that's why that's why it was
so easy to do that popular and you could
not hire writers and get AI to do it and
okay the writing might not be very good
but it'll be popular then again I don't
think that survives today's climate of
of Television it just I I as much as I
would enjoy that episode
they did this and they're like yep let's
do it right they're then going to feed
the data points back into it and say
yeah that was great you did a really
good job AI well done
right what's gonna happen again they're
gonna do the same movie again
the same movie again it is
what we've been doing for the last 20
years
no no
no it will be literally the same movie
again no no
one thinks AI is good at is reformat and
making it look a bit different
because it can just do different
iterations are the same thing and and
when you break it down it'll be the same
thing but it won't look but most movies
most blockbuster movies
are very formulaic they run to a set of
rules is this
is a good time for me to bring up
guardians of galaxy vol 3.
if you'd like
because I mean talking about
formulaic it was layers of formula
that's surrendered
but I mean don't you think like volume 3
was just layers upon layers of formulaic
dialogue and plots and
yeah
and you know Exposition loopholes I mean
it was a uh
question I mean
yeah so I saw volume three
this is a couple nights ago whatever and
it was just like oh wait a minute this
is part of this movie this is part of
this movie and they've kind of stitched
all this together you know and finally
we get Rocky Raccoon I mean it was to me
it was just like
it was not seated from by anybody you
know it was you know it was much like
Matt was saying you know once you you
know if you take all the Iron Man comics
and you you know stir them into an AI
pot you're going to get Iron Man out you
know it's just like it was every
I mean it was just trope-filled I
thought and I know you guys discussed
volume three before what's your feelings
on that concerning
Trope and uh layers and layers
of just formulaic I love the movie but
it was very much
ah
if you when before you go in you pretty
much knew what that film was gonna be
right yeah because it was the third in
the series it was the final one so it
was going to have a certain turn that
you expected
um there was nothing in that film that
surprised me I loved it but there's
nothing in the film that surprised me
um maybe the ending the ending was a
little surprised and I have to admit the
way they redid the read at the ending
basically but they did it in a way
because they're getting ready for the
sequels
and that's not surprising
so not surprising was the the lack of
deaths I guess uh but because they were
ready for the spin-offs so that just
made my uh
it made my brain tick right there uh
um but
that's I guess that that kind of brings
what we were just saying about phase
four versus phase one and two there a
second ago guardians galaxy feels much
more like a phase one or two film in
their formula which made it a breath of
fresh air for what we've gotten recently
within Marvel so whenever it's like semi
formula with uh that because it is very
formulaic of course but that's kind of
like the difference I guess where uh the
phase four feels like it could have been
written by an AI because it's just it's
just there it doesn't feel genuine you
can tell all of it was filmed during
like or a good chunk of it was filmed
during the pandemic and they had to
rearrange schedule so okay this plot
line taken out here we'll we'll shoehorn
a little tiny one here boom boom boom
boom boom all these little different
kind of things uh versus something that
feels like phase one or phase two that
might not be like
truly special in a lot of ways but it
feels a lot more special
just just because of the way it was made
versus just
oh spider website the question for you
then how long do you think it'll be if
ever you can say never
until we will have a cinematic release
summer blockbuster that is completely
written by AI
I mean you could do it next year I think
someone will try to do it yeah but I
don't think it would be popular maybe it
will because it will be the first AI
generated film and it will be popular
because it's
um
yeah different and they'll advertise it
like crazy as people want to see what
it's like yeah and so
and that will spawn other other people
to maybe maybe do it but they won't be
the fat will dry out essentially
like it's not gonna be it's not gonna be
something that people do
consistently because because it's just
going to be generating the same sort of
things over and over again very
formulaic very blah blah whatever
we as audiences are going to notice and
we're going to be really annoyed by that
which the studios if they have any sense
which I'm hoping they do because they
want to make money
they must have some Sans J they want to
make money yeah that's the point they
want to make money yeah yeah so they'll
then use AI as a tool rather than to do
it all for them
so okay the question I think you want to
ask Jay is not like when that film's
gonna happen because like you could you
could say uh uh a film the first film
that makes a hundred million dollars or
the first film that makes a a billion
dollars from Strictly AI but there's
still going to be three four five six
eight twelve twenty Thirty forty dozens
and dozens and dozens of names behind
that
I mean I would argue that the script is
just the first step AI is capable of
doing a lot more
yeah I
can see that
I can see
because AI is such a big thing now it's
a big talking point
I it wouldn't surprise me if there was
someone out there now fully developing a
movie so they do the script they do the
voice over they do the animation slash
uh deep fake slash whatever they want to
do it wouldn't surprise me if they want
if they if someone was doing that and I
think it would be quite popular because
it's new and it's like let's see how the
AI performs but it's not sustainable
it's not something that they're going to
do forever
I I really think that the only time that
we actually need to hurt like worry is
is if all these different names are
still in the credits we're okay but if
you see one producer's name and the AI
has done everything else and maybe one
producer and like a director or even if
that producer's the director as well
then we should worry but as long as
there's more than one name in that
credit list
I think we're all right
several years ago that uh
was
partially produced or written or
something by an AI
or wasn't it like um
short film Maybe
yeah I could I could say a short film
I don't think it was a cinematic release
I think we'd know oh so I was just going
to say earlier that I think it would be
very easy to get a Blockbuster
you know a profitable one off of AI
quite easily because
um
I mean that's just a function of
marketing not necessarily a form of
talent I mean there's been a lot of
blockbuster movies that absolutely
sucked and it was just because they had
very clever marketing so maybe the issue
is not necessarily the movie itself is
can when will we have a a movie that
where the marketing is AI created maybe
that's where we really need to go and I
would argue that I I would be amazing at
that because again it rules there's a
very simple set of rules that they run
marketing to to get people interested
um and that would be very easy
um like I say I I I'm hoping that thanks
to these scripts Hollywood aren't going
to go this way because they're putting
these rules I think the AI cannot be a
person but it could be used to generate
I mean if I was an animator I think I'd
be quite worried about AI because I
think an anime AI will quite quickly do
an awful lot of
animation work and we'll take a look and
if I was an animator if I was an
animator living in Hollywood I'd be
great if I still have a job because they
all moved to India anyway but if I think
it's going to put animators out of
business that'll work I should say
I think maybe we've got a bit more a bit
safer I mean we have to be honest we
don't actually know what ai's going to
be like in 10 years we don't but that
looks like the way it's going
but if you give it a story and tell it I
want to animate this this and this that
actually
it can do a lot of the heavy lifting I
mean you'd still have to have somebody
come in and designing characters and
things but if somebody designed a
character and they go right the AI
That's the character
I think a lot of the work it would it
would do a lot for post-production I
don't think it would do a lot for the
actual creation so people who actually
do the preliminary animation
um obviously they're going to be doing
most of the leg work if they then
decided that they wanted
as an example change his shirt then they
could whack into another algorithm so
just change the show to this I think
yeah
it would work well for that but I don't
think it would work well for actually
creating an entire
consistent consistent like
um
what's what's the word I'm looking for
how shows have a certain look and feel
like you can instantly tell the symptoms
yeah you could tell similar to The
Simpsons by the way it's animated you
can tell future trauma by the way where
it is Rick and Morty as well it's very
certain
themes are very certain style that AI
I don't it will always be slightly
different with each frame and it would
look very disjointed I think so if it
was why if it's animating it to a set of
rules then again it'd be AI working with
application software that already exists
so if you if you create a character and
say tell that the outright this is the
character I want it to do this storyline
why couldn't an AI do that and and again
you would tell it the style you would
tell it the thing and you would I mean I
think they'd have to be somewhere with
creative doing certain elements of it to
get you know the feet like you said the
tone and the feeling right but and I'm
not saying that the AI would do all of
the work what I'm saying is the anime
the AI could do a lot of the heavy
lifting which instead of having contain
animators you could have one animated
where you needed to touch things up or
you needed to replace certain things or
add something into it but not
the main domain animating part like the
story but maybe the storyboarding stage
you could probably do that
but like the actual animating and the
animated rigging and stuff and like
actually like getting the characters to
move in a way that they actually want
them to move like very nuanced movements
rather than
we wanted to walk across across across
across the road because the way an
artificial intelligence or whatever it's
gonna
um determine how he's going to walk is
based on
how it's seen other things walking but
it might not be the right walk for that
scene yeah come in and fine-tune it and
it's going to generate
and
you might go through 50 60 variations
where you could have just had a an
artist just just do it
but I would argue that's like animation
now how you know like how we got
animation
um say the the Ronald uh um the zemeckis
um the northern northern Express movie a
few years ago with Tom where Tom Hanks
played everybody
um The Polar Express sorry and the CGI
was excellent most of the time but the
mouse they couldn't quite get the mouth
right and at times it was creepy as hell
and I think that's what if you had
AIC yeah that's kind of what it would be
like a bit it would it would come out
like that and you just then you'd have
to have somebody go over it just to take
out the
the bits that aren't but in a similar
sense that if you have
um if you sort of do a painting and it's
perfect it doesn't and perfectly
symmetrical it looks weird because our
faces aren't symmetrical and we're
designed to be able to sort of tell you
know those like subtle differences
so you'd have to do that as you'd almost
have to I did a human being to go and
dirty it up a little bit
but that's way more work it's a lot
harder to do that stuff post than it is
when you're doing it because you because
because think about it all these things
have got layers
um layers added onto it and then the AI
thinks all this is done so it renders
out as a final image with all these
layers or all these like on top of it
it's not going to like give you a uh I
don't know what animation software
exists laughter effects file for example
it's going to give you a an mp4
going and then editing that MP4 is going
to be a lot more work because you have
to work you have to
take out the bit you want
recreate the the layers and the effects
that make it like blend in properly and
then do that for every single frame
it's just way more way more work I don't
think you would though because again
you'd be working with the AI to do it so
what you do instead you would change the
parameters of what the AI has done but
if the AI
because you would tell it what what you
want to change that's the point and and
an AI well like you said is just a piece
of software it's just work into a set of
rules you just adjust the rules
and then it would reanimate it it would
regenerate it for you yeah but anyway it
would but I I I'll say I think it would
you would end up going through 50 60
variations or whatever meaning it takes
for you to say yep that's perfect but
the amount of time that would have taken
you might as well have just had an
animated do it anyway
mm-hmm well I I I'd almost look at it in
the same way we looked at uh right we're
like yes it could be we're we're right
now it's it's the same thing you have a
writer's room you have an animating room
and it's not death by committee was it
animators because it takes that many
people to put that much focus into
making something that looked that good
but with the lessening of that and you
can do it with half the amount of people
I don't necessarily think that means
half the amount of people are getting
paid I think that means that's
twice as many people making creative
individual art or creative art for their
own projects or whatever they want to do
versus just a a whole studio having to
hire 30 40 50 60 people or something
like that where instead if it if it's an
animation house and that company has 30
40 50 60 employees they could be on
40 different projects at that time
instead of two I think that opens up
everybody's availability and opportunity
that much more I I think AI is the great
equalizer in a lot of ways same thing it
is with writing I I think of course as
humans we put our own scare it's fears
on kind of things with we tend to fear
Monger things look at our news every bit
of our news is is fear-mongering
warmongering hellmongering and that's
where our brains go to we're
survivalists we're
the 115 pound bags of water and flesh
meant to adapt to anything to survive is
kind of the way people are you know
I'm just saying a general thing I'm not
way more than that right now there's a
distinct lack of bacon mongering
throughout the media I think oh I had
two pounds of bacon yesterday so I might
be on the bacon mongering so
is it fair to say that this is exactly
the same argument that we would have had
if if we did this 30 years ago when CGI
was coming in and computer generated
things were coming in or this would be
that same argument
I was going to say this earlier it's
like we would have had the same argument
when computers first came in
whenever there's a new technology people
get scared because they think it's going
to replace them and maybe it will
replace some people but it's gonna also
create so many more opportunities for
other people so what's the problem
is a book when you have a technology the
more powerful a technology is it also
true though the the more risk it comes
with
Power Nuclear Power is awesome but it is
risky genetic engineering will give us
could could eliminate disease
too
it could grow hair damn it but there's a
dark side to it it's gonna grow mine no
that's that's not happening
um we're talking about genetic
engineering not Miracles
um
but then but that's my point though the
more
the bigger the advantage to a new
technology the bigger the risk computers
themselves you know there's there's huge
advantages but there are big risks you
know with like losing your data over
Reliance Etc so
and when I would I I don't think I would
argue is we do have to be careful we do
have to learn from our own past
experiences and when we have a
technology that's as capable as AI
proper AI as well could become
we do have to think ahead and we do have
to put in precautions and we do have to
I mean Elon Musk says AI is potentially
the biggest risk we face today it's more
dangerous than nuclear weapon nuclear
war potentially
it is but I don't think it is for the
reasons he thinks it is I think it's
because of our
over-reliance on
machines
I think we as a as a society as kind of
dumbing down
because we're not look we're not doing
things ourselves but even even me now
like when I go downstairs and I make
dinner I'm going to say hey Alexa set a
timer I'm not going to look at my watch
on my phone or anything like that
but that's a very simple thing but like
we rely on these virtual assistants and
these tools to do quite a lot and that
is a risk
but
I don't know what I'm trying to say but
it's like
sorry
going back to uh something that you know
Jay was talking about is you know well
would would we've had this discussion
with CGI I remember when uh Star Wars
came out it used a lot of
a lot of set designers were complaining
about matte paintings
you know they you know they'd have no
m-a-t-t-e matte paintings like map world
back in the day huh
set up map paintings
you know the the set designers
complained a lot about matte paintings
being used in uh in Star Wars and how it
triggered a lot of matte paintings and
uh then there was this company called
mat world that you know hey let's do it
for everybody then you see lots of map
paintings in Indiana Jones movies and so
forth then you had a lot of the matte
painters started complaining when they
just did it digitally you know in
Photoshop and then just created the
image and then pasted it over and
there's no actual real painting So then
the matte painters started complaining
about the CGI
you know and now we don't use matte
paintings anymore or anything like that
because we always keep the camera moving
so I think people just like complaining
uh well they do and that goes back to
Harris's thing is just like you know all
of our media is hate and fear
yeah Sex and Death
that's what that's what sells Sex and
Death
if you can if you guys
go on sorry house
oh no I was just joking I said I like my
reggae music too much I'm an optimistic
bastard
well guys I think I won that argument I
don't know what you guys think but um
I'm probably sure um I don't think we
ever I I still have about 15 films that
I could go through that
throws a couple quickly and I'll tell
you if I think their derivative and what
they're based on just just because we've
already been over the Tarantino and
glorious bastards what's the time once
upon a time in Hollywood Pulp Fiction if
we're going Chris Nolan Inception
Memento Prestige tenant if we're going
uh get outs there 2001 A Space Odyssey
if we're going to Richard's link later
again not just Boyhood have you seen A
Scanner Darkly oh my God
no computer it feels like a computer
came up with it but no computer would
ever come up with it also first cow uh
Kelly reichardt's film that we talked
about uh like last week it was just the
Slow Burn example that's the thing we
keep talking about slow Burns for that
movie is completely Unholy original with
it being also like it seemingly wouldn't
be but it is which is great uh but then
the one that comes to mind is like
besides all of a24's Library I could say
the lighthouse I could say the Green
Knight I could say a whole bunch of
things uh the Green Knight lesso because
it is book but
Donnie Darko no AI is coming up with
Donnie Darko any day of the week
I arrest my case
all of those films though are based on
see the AI agrees don't get me wrong
it's hard it's how small you want to go
and how you know how Basics you want to
go but every single one of those films
will either be based on a love story or
Revenge story a Redemption story
um I can't remember what the other two
are sorry but there are basically five
or six
basic plot mechanisms that every single
movie story anything ever written is
based on is that plot mechanisms or
those just truly human emotions that
plot mechanisms
basic plots basic whatever whatever
words you want to call it like a
Redemption story is it is you know
basically every spaghetti western ever
made you could argue that Star Wars in
someone else is a Redemption story
um
they're a hero's journey then as well
but I mean but I would say that the
heroes in lots of elements is about
and redeeming themselves but anyway but
yeah the point is that there's there
there are only about six stories ever
been told and every other story ever
since is is a variation of those themes
those six basic themes
and nothing if you look if you think of
it like that nothing is original
I would argue though that what you then
do with those six stories is is what you
then have whether you think something's
original not how you treat it what you
do with it
um a perspective on things Etc and if
you take a different perspective on
something you can argue that the Matrix
on a basic level is a love story and a
uh you know like a hero Journey
um but the way they did it we've never
seen anything like it before
so is that in that case is that original
on a basic level no but on several other
levels it is so it's really but I mean
it's I think it's an argument you can't
win if I'm going to be a dick about it
is my point well I mean humans like to
oversimplify things that's why we're
inherently lazy in a lot of ways and
like that's why a lot of our fears with
AI is like oh how can it take over this
task for us how can we take over this
task for us how can it do this job for
us is because we want to be lazy we're
inherently trying to find the easiest
solution for something and I think we
can sometimes the hardest thing to do
yeah and and well not well because you
can you can just base it off of emotions
and the way humans react to things and
yeah there are like the six different
types of stories but it that's just
boiled down to human emotion that's just
understanding people and a certain level
in a psychological level I don't think
that's more so because yes anything can
have like six archetypes around their
story but silence the Lambs is not that
similar to get out and and its
archetypes are very similar there uh I
think that that's just it's it's not a
gross oversimplication but it is an
oversimplification nonetheless that I
think we as as human beings tend to just
try to do too often there's a lot more
than and then six stories out there uh
it's just if you really want to boil it
and make it down into that you could do
that
but but it's more complicating that we
can all agree it's way more complicated
yeah yeah
but do you actually genuinely believe a
an AI or a computer can't simulate or
actually have emotions
and emotions are basically just a
reaction to
[Music]
um
physical stimulus
um chemical reaction in the brain and
um
past
um experiences can you imagine if clippy
turned out to be an AI
how how much it would have ruin
everything
yeah I hated Clippy clippy had all my
disdain all my anger all my frustration
was funneled into [__] [__] clippy
would you like help today no goddammit I
don't want any help get the [__] away
from me say I had been 10 times as worse
I just think as human beings I think
sometimes we think we're special and
that we have a soul or something and
there's something that's
um unique about the way we think or
something then we're not we just have we
have an organism and they used to do
stimulus response and psychology so they
do in theory if you have a stimulus you
should always get the same response but
then they realize there's an organism in
between so now they say stimulus
organism response
and that's how we then understand
response but most human behavior is
completely
um understandable and predictable
um because we're not that complicated
well very sophisticated
system it's just more complicated
for lack of a better example my texting
will show uh whenever you're hunting and
and you're you're going after a deer or
something like that if you if you don't
hit it right if it's not dropping and
you need to go in the brush and follow
it just for a little bit
ninety percent of the time that deer is
going to take the easiest path so you
you know which path it's going to take
whether you're actually tracking like if
it's losing blood or anything uh uh
you're following the most likely
scenario and people unlike robots are
maybe a little more than 150 pounds but
we're 150 plus pounds of adaptable bags
of water and flesh that's literally what
we are and I don't think someone would
adapt in those same ways when you're in
a fight or you're hunting people they
are very predictable
yeah and and I think a robot can predict
those things but I I don't think a
robot's similar or an AI is similar in
that manner that's that's it's it's not
adaptable in that same way it tries to
adapt its environment to it versus we
adapt to our environment I guess yeah I
think the main reason why I think in it
in a fight I'm thinking from a military
point of view they're very predictable
because
that trained
yeah and you you fight to a set of rules
and um or that you know those rules that
are trained into you so that's why the
soldiers are incredibly predictable if
you understand the training of different
the French fight completely different to
Germans and completely different the
Americans and if you understand their
basic training principles they're very
very predictable
um which is why we're the best at it
because we're actually trying to not be
predictable so
we are the best
how many decades did United States
trained jihadis in the Middle East to
fight just like us and then all of a
sudden we go to Iraq and guess what
they're fighting like us
well you went over and talked on
guerrilla warfare oh yeah
yeah we fought in Northern Ireland we
had we learned the hard way about
fighting and fighting
we showed the bridge a little bit about
guerrilla warfare back in uh I mean you
know if you want to talk about guerrilla
warfare I mean let's look at the 1700s
in the Appalachian Mountains somebody
got their asses kicked we taught y'all
guerrilla warfare excuse me we've never
lost a war ever uh there's a reason this
country exists we were fighting Napoleon
and we let you get away with it we we
beat you twice and we kept having to
pull back because Napoleon
and we were fighting other Wars so we
were just like I'll leave them too so
those are adaptable excuses to losing a
war we didn't we didn't lose we I think
there's an entire continent from this
side of the world that would argue
bravely left you to it oh no that's what
we have never lost there was a Mal
Murray thing and he talked about this
and says we've never lost a war ever
um but and actually genuinely speaking I
don't think we ever have
um but it was something like we've been
we've been at War at one point Britain
has been at War at one point or another
with every country on the planet
and that existed uh that existed the
turn of the century so you know there's
like new there's a few new questions but
basically we've been at war with every
planet on the country at one point or
another
um every country and I'm just like that
come on Britain I tell you what we go
abroad and you get a few jars in us we
we get fighty yeah the the only three
Wars that Google says the britons have
ever lost the britons the British have
ever lost the American Revolutionary War
the Napoleonic Wars and then the Boer
War how did we lose the Napoleonic Wars
we put him in prison twice
we controlled it for 200 years following
it and we didn't lose the war of
independence we just didn't care enough
yeah I'm sure that's what the french
would say you know at the Battle of
Yorktown just yeah
yeah we just didn't care and if we were
just laugh I'll just let him have it
they want it let's let them have it okay
did we lose the Napoleonic Wars
I mean I don't know that's what Google
said I'm not I don't know I wasn't going
too deep do we or do we not speak French
no no we don't we won the war
and then we control Calais for 100 years
after it we still control Calais now
really
um
um anyway
the military
didn't go as planned all right but other
than that it went very well anyway guys
thanks so much for that we've had a
lovely argument
um that that I won and
um I look forward
to many more
that's what the AI thought about that
whenever a new technology comes along
and it's a it's when AI is replaced by
something else
we'll argue about it then as well
if I could just so quickly mention that
the proper titles of those two books I
spoke about earlier uh the first one was
story style structure substance and the
principles of screenwriting by Robert
McKee that's the one that's a required
reading for a new uh Pixar uh writers
the other one is uh a little bit older
it's Poetics by Aristotle that was like
the
first attempt to imagine like quantify
storytelling or how to tell a story and
those both of those are really good uh
reads
yeah and that's what we just give back
to Ai and then the rest of Hollywood can
go on because that's done anyway thank
you so much guys I was absolutely
brilliant and um for the Americans in
the room and on the chat I'm joking
Britain is better than everybody else on
the planet but only because of like
Shakespeare's stuff not because of
fighting and even though we are better
at fighting
that's not a very good apology but
rescuing I'm joking
calm down don't get into the comments
I'm joking
but guys thank you so so much go and
have breakfast stormy I will
whoever's new chat gbt in there is in
the comment section is excellent it just
cracked me up
but uh no that was a that was a
fascinating tea bags in the Boston
Harbor that's just
I'm gonna be generous and actually say
that I was only 75 right and that you
you made some good points there you go
so that that's how we'll end the
conversation but um everybody have a
brilliant day and um we'll see you soon
we'll see you next week
boo yeah I'm online
and the stream for me please yeah uh
Matt you're up you're up demand
bye